hey guys this video is going to give you
a glimpse into what my training looks
like right now as a lot of you probably
know I've ended up having to take off
about 14 weeks of training total in the
past five months with some head issues
and an oblique strain that I thought was
a hernia and then it took a while to set
up a doctor's appointment so I'm just
getting back in the swing of things and
the point of this video is just so you
kind of get an idea of what my training
looks like as I'm trying to get back to
full strength so it's four days a week
first day is shoulder dominant pressing
and upper body second day is deadlifts
and some other lower body accessory work
day three is bench dominant pressing and
other upper body work and a4 is
squatting and then morphic dominant
accessories I didn't get video recorded
for all of it we're working out at a
commercial gym now they don't like
people to bring in recording devices in
so I might not be able to get video of a
lot of sessions but that's fine and
especially on the present stuff since my
wife spots me I wouldn't have anyone to
take video I'm not going to be bringing
a tripod
so here my deadlifts beltless 495
conventional and sumo they actually
moved a lot faster on video than they
felt when I was doing them
here's Lindsay she uh she was having
some bash issues for a while we're not
100% sure what the cause of them was
actually but she's just getting back
into bed with me she's pulled 335 so
obviously 185 or 135 I mean it's really
light for her so she's enjoying being
back under the bar serious with it again
there's bench day I vastly overestimated
what I could do I was thinking 365 would
be a fairly easy mate as I've done 405
for each before I wanted eight but five
was all that was happening that's okay
though
here's footage from the squat day squat
is the only lift that never leaves me
this is my second squad session back
after not squatting her six weeks
and 5:45 for one follows them to to
regular felt pretty decent my quads felt
like they got hit by a truck the next
day but strength wise it's it's still
there I feel like I could probably still
hit something in the mid 6s anyway so
that's just a look at what a typical
week of training looks like right now
I'm also in a deficit trying to cut a
little bit of weight hopefully maybe
make the 231 class for us APL or at
least comfortably be a 242 again so
training volumes also lower than it
would be because of that but you know at
this point I haven't really been
training so my sensitivity to a given
level of stress is quite high compared
to what it typically would be so I just
don't need as much volume as I would if
I had been training consistently for a
long period of time
alright guys well that's about it thanks
for watching bye